hagamos otro ejemplo acerca de
coeficientes indeterminados pero esta
vez voy a cambiar hdx voy a tomar la
misma ecuación diferencial que la vez
pasada para obtener sus raíces
fácilmente va a ser la ecuación de mi
prima menos tres veces 10 prima menos 4
y esto va a ser igual a una función de x
pero esta vez no me voy a tomar una
función exponencial esta vez voy a
cambiar a tomar una función
trigonométricas de hecho voy a tomar la
función dos veces el seno de x
tomé esta ecuación diferencial la misma
que la vez pasada porque quiero que
ustedes se acuerden que ya habíamos
sacado sus raíces del polinomio
característico asociado a la ecuación
homogénea ojo a la ecuación igualdad a
cero y nosotros nos habíamos dado que
sus raíces del polinomio característico
eran cuatro y menos uno espero que se
acuerden y si no pueden revisar el vídeo
anterior entonces teníamos que la
solución de la parte homogénea o de la
parte igualada cero si ustedes se
acuerdan era una constante por e a la 4x
y a esto le sumamos la segunda constante
por el ala menos x porque la segunda
raíz era menos 1 muy bien ahora lo que
quiero ver es qué va a pasar si yo tengo
esta función y necesito encontrar una
solución particular
pero hacemos un poco la lógica si
nosotros ponemos aquí una función que
sea exponencial o logarítmica o
polinomiales y yo la sustituyó su
primera derivada y su segunda derivada
pues no me va a dar seno de x realmente
si nosotros nos ponemos a preguntar
quién es esa función pues esa función va
a ser ni más ni menos que algo que tenga
que ver con senos y cosenos de hecho voy
a tomar una combinación de senos y
cosenos si yo derivó el seno y el poseen
ovidio 4 derivada del seno y el cose no
tienen que ver con seno están de acuerdo
muy bien entonces voy a tomar mi
solución particular voy a proponer que
sea una famosa y y ésta la voy a ser
igual a quien la voy a hacer y bueno
bien pues voy a decir que ya es igual a
a veces el seno de x y porque pueden con
el seno de x pues recuerden que el seno
tiene que ver con el seno cuando luego
tenemos dos veces y cuando lo derivó una
vez
pero no solo el seno que cumple esa
propiedad también la otra función que
cumple esa propiedad que tiene que ver
con el celo pues es el cosenos igual
coseno lo derivó dos veces y lo derivó
una vez tiene que ver con el seno
también entonces le voy a tener que
agregar a esta función pues otra
constante le voy a llamar para bebés es
el coseno de x
bien y le pongo a y b y recuerden que
nosotros lo que tenemos que encontrar es
esta y esta vez tenemos que saber los
valores de a&b para ello encontrar así
mi solución particular y acabé pero lo
que necesito es derivar la entonces
vamos a derivar con mucho cuidado esta
función
si yo derivó el seno de x pues es el
coseno de x entonces me queda a veces el
coste no de x pero la derivada del coste
no es el menos cero entonces me va a
quedar menos veces el seno de x bien ya
se dan cuenta que otra vez tiene que ver
con el seno ahora voy a red derivar es
decir voy a hacer la segunda derivada la
derivada del 12 no es el menos seno
entonces me va a quedar menos a veces
seno de equis derivada del pse no puede
ser coseno entonces va a quedar menos
veces el coseno de x bien se cuenta que
las matemáticas realmente son a tener
conocimientos de matemáticas elementales
un poco de álgebra o un poco de
trigonometría un poco de aritmética y no
equivocarse es muy importante no cometer
errores
de hecho yo siempre que digo esto comete
errores entonces vaya
las cuentas por favor bien ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es sustituir de mi
prima de prima que en la ecuación
original y resolver para ahí para ver en
esto habíamos quedado entonces pues
vamos a resolverlo si yo sustituyó pues
lleve prima me queda menos a veces el
seno de x ya esto le restaba bebés es el
coseno de x bien pero después dice menos
tres veces y prima o sea menos tres
veces que prima que es a coste no de x
de seno de x
entonces me va a quedar menos por menos
más me ha quedado tres veces b seno de x
y después menos tres por a me va a
quedar menos tres a por él coseno dx muy
bien bien
ya tengo que es tres veces el seno de x
menos tres arcos seno de x
y después me dice que a esto le reste
cuatro veces la función original tal
cual sin ninguna derivada entonces me
quedan menos cuatro veces hacen o de
equis y pues menos cuatro veces de
coseno de equis
fíjense que yo a como de el seno abajo
del seno y el coche no abajo el coche no
porque así de esta manera me es más
fácil de a sumarlos pero todo esto tiene
que ser igual ni más ni menos que a dos
veces el seno de x bien ya por fin
estemos acomodados como yo quería y es
muy fácil entonces poder hacer esta
operación y esta operación y lo que me
salga me va a quedar con cosas que tenga
que ver con seno y con cose no menos a
más
3b - 4a pues esto es menos al menos 4 a
es menos 5 a más 3 ve por el seno de
equis o muy importante y por el otro
lado tenemos que menos ve menos tres a
menos cuatro pues la ve y la cuatro
veces suman entonces voy a quedar a
menos tres a y esto menos 5 b
y esto que multiplica claro al coseno de
x no se mueve vidas entonces voy a poner
aquí coseno de x estabilidad estar aquí
solamente que ya no me cupo hagan bien y
con mucho cuidado y con mucho espacio
las cuentas para que no se equivoquen
pero bueno a que quiero decir con esto
pues que menos 53 b tiene que ser igual
al coeficiente que está al lado d
el seno de x del otro lado o sea igual a
2 y por otra parte tengo que menos tres
a menos 520 tiene que ser igual al
coeficiente que está al lado del coseno
de x pero miren me falta una rayita aquí
viene menos tres a menos sin comer
tienen que ser lo que está al lado del
consejo de x pero que no parece cosa de
equis o sea que es cero veces cosas no
de equis y esto me va a dar pie a que yo
ya puedo escribir un sistema de
ecuaciones que tenga que ver solamente
con la y solamente con ver entonces me
va a quedar que menos 5 a 3 b pues es
igual a 2 que era el coeficiente que
estaba lado del seno y menos tres a
menos 5 b pues esto tiene que ser igual
a cero porque cero pues porque es el
coeficiente que está dado el coche no
recuerden que el coche no aparecía
tengo ya un sistema de ecuaciones un
sistema de ecuaciones que yo sé resolver
por varios métodos suma resta igualación
sustitución determinantes método gráfico
por el método que yo quiera pero es una
cosa de álgebra elemental y lo voy a
resolver por schumer extra así que voy a
multiplicar la ecuación número uno por
cinco tercios cinco tercios por cinco
pues es 25 tercios de estos blanco en
mañana van a ver y cinco tercios por
tres pues es 5b y esto tiene que ser
igual a dos por cinco tercios que
pusieron diez tercios muy bien y la
ecuación de abajo la voy a dejar tal
cual igualita y me va a quedar menos
tres a menos cinco p es igual a cero y
ahora si los voy a sumar diez tercios
más cero pues son dispersos 520 menos
cinco veces se van es lo que quería y
menos 25 tercios sea menos 3 a pues me
queda menos 25 tercios y le voy a poner
el 3 lo voy a escribir como nueve
tercios me va a ser mucho más fácil así
restar los entonces me va a quedar menos
nueve tercios d
bien y de aquí yo ya puedo despegar a
esta un poco tal ayudo y no se ve muy
bonito pero ya podemos sacar al menos 25
tercios menos nueve tercios de a pues
esto yo lo puedo restar 25 más 5 son 30
treinta y cuatro tercios de a y esto es
igual a diez a tercios y el tres aquí y
el tres a cada vámonos no me sirve lo
puedo eliminar y así que apoyo despejará
mucho más fácil estos 10 34 años y de
hecho puede simplificar la mitad de 10
65 y la mitad de 34 2007 ya puedo decir
que es 5 sobre 17 bien pues ahora voy a
sustituir en mi ecuación más sencilla
que es ecuación número 2
me quedan menos tres veces a pero ya sé
cuánto vale
entonces me va a quedar menos tres veces
5 17 ambos menos 5 b esto es igual a
cero y si yo multiplico por el menos 3
pues me queda menos 15 sobre 17 es igual
a 5 ve a positivo 5 ve muy bien
de hecho aquí aquí hay algo raro porque
me quedaba positivo donde está el signo
que me falta aquí piense menos 25
tercios menos nueve tercios era menos
treinta y cuatro tercios no me
corrigieron van a ver y entonces este
signo pues se pasa para acá y también
para acá y entonces también se pasa para
acá y entonces menos por menos me va a
dar más bien aquí estaba el signo que me
faltaba van a ver y entonces 15 sobre 17
entre 5 pues me voy a quedar 3 17 años
bien ven vale 13 entre 17 y de hecho esa
fue la parte difícil de este ejercicio
se dan cuenta el no perder los signos
negativos y no equivocarse este fue un
ejercicio rudo y de hecho voy a cambiar
otro color que espero no los ponga más
nauseabundos y voy a decir que la
solución particular de mí no mojen ea
pues me va a quedar sustituyendo a yahvé
menos 5 sobre 17 por el seno de x
y tres veces sobre 17 el coseno de x
bien si se dan cuenta ya acabó de
construir todo lo que necesitaba ya
tengo la solución general de mi parte
homogénea que es estar acá la voy a
atrapar y la solución particular de mi
parte no homogénea que es estar acá y
como ya habíamos visto la suma de la
general homogénea y la suma de la
particular era mi solución general de
lan homogénea pero ella se fuera de
tiempo así que mi frase célebre nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo